hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream diese Meldung hat gestern Abend
vor allem den Westen und auch die NATO
in hohe Alarmbereitschaft versetzt
zeitgleich zur russischen Luftangriffen
auf die Ukraine ist eine Rakete in Polen
eingeschlagen mindestens zwei Menschen
starben dabei die Rakete die ist hier
auf dem Gelände eines
landwirtschaftlichen Betriebs in
schewadov eingeschlagen das ist ein Dorf
ganz im Osten des Landes keine zehn
Kilometer von der Grenze zur Ukraine
entfernt
hier sehen wir Bilder die den Einschlag
von gestern zeigen sollen und wir wollen
heute genau darauf gucken was genau ist
da passiert wer steckt hinter dem
Raketeneinschlag und wie reagiert auch
die Regierung in Warschau und auch die
NATO den aktuellen Stand angesicherten
Informationen den wollen wir jetzt mit
euch im Stream aufbereiten stellt
deswegen gerne eure Fragen in die Chats
oder per Mail an die Adresse die ihr
jetzt seht ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de
heute Vormittag ist die NATO in Brüssel
zu einer Krisensitzung zusammengekommen
gleich wird Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg auch auf einer
Pressekonferenz erste Einschätzungen und
Informationen zum Stand der Dinge
bekannt geben die Pressekonferenz die
seht ihr live bei uns wir schalten jetzt
aber erstmal zu Florian neu an für uns
vor Ort in Brüssel da haben wir ihn
hallo Florian was sind deine aktuellen
Informationen von vor Ort
die Pressekonferenz wird in der Tat
gleich beginnen nachdem die Sitzung die
gedringlichkeitssitzung der
nato-botschafter jetzt gerade vorbei ist
die wichtigste Botschaft wird sein dass
man hierzu Besonnenheit aufruft keine
voreiligen Schlüsse ziehen wird die
irgendwie die Gefahr in der direkten
Konfrontation zwischen der Nato und
Russland erhöhen könnten gestern Abend
haben ja bereits erste auch namhafte
Politiker auf Russland als Urheber
dieses Angriffes verwiesen unter anderem
auch der ukrainische Präsident wo Leute
mir selenski das stellt sich nun heute
aber etwas anders da nachdem wir etwa
vom US-Präsidenten Joe Biden gehört
haben dass seine Ansicht nach nach
Erkenntnissen der US Regierung ist eher
eine ukrainische Rakete war andererseits
wird aber auch darauf verwiesen etwa vom
deutschen Bundeskanzler das ja diese
ukrainische Rakete eine abwehrrakete war
also nur eine Folge des russischen
Angriffskrieges insofern die wichtigste
Botschaft hier wird sein man wird
weiterhin den Krieg Russlands
verurteilen aber keine Eskalation herbei
beschwören sozusagen sondern zu
Besonderheit und zu einer genauen
Untersuchung dieses Vorfalls aufrufen ja
und auch eine weitere ganz frische
Information Polens Präsident duda hat
sich auch vor wenigen Minuten geäußert
und gesagt und von keinem gezielten
Angriff sondern von einem unglücklichen
Unfall gesprochen eine weitere Frage die
sich daraus ergibt Florian wenn du sagst
die Aussagen von Joe Biden das ist sich
um eine ukrainische Flugabwehrrakete
handeln könnte auch die Informationen
aus Belgien die das bestätigen sind
damit sozusagen die Einleitung der
Verfahren der nato-verfahren Artikel 4
und Artikel 5 das was gestern Abend noch
im Raum stand vom Tisch
das muss man so sagen ganz klar man muss
auch diese beiden Verfahren auch noch
mal differenzieren Artikel 4 ist nicht
der Bündnisfall Artikel 4 heißt dass ein
NATO Staat jederzeit Konsultationen
einbeziehen einberufen kann wenn ihr das
Gefühl hat dass seine Staatsgebiet in
Gefahr ist und es stand gestern Abend in
der Tat im Raum das Polen diesen Artikel
4 zu Konsultationen eben ziehen würde
aber darauf hat die polnische Regierung
nun offenbar verzichtet man will auch
hier erst einmal abwarten und diese wohl
angespannte Situation sehr
verantwortungsvoll managen so sagt die
mir an der Fachhandel Diplomat gerade
eben Artikel 5 der Bündnis weil das wäre
das schärfste Schwert der NATO der
besagt ja dass ein Angriff auf ein Land
als Angriff auf alle anderen verstanden
wird aber dieser Artikel ist in weiter
Ferne von Bündnisfall spricht hier
niemand und es wird auch glaube ich nach
dieser Pressekonferenz klargestellt
werden dass Artikel 5 auf keinen Fall
gezogen wird zumal der ja auch von allen
30 Alliierten erst einmal einstimmig
beschlossen werden müsste also der ist
noch wirklich zum Glück
weiter Ferne während wir weiter auf den
Beginn der Pressekonferenz von
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg warten
sprechen wir mit Florian neuhahn in
Brüssel über die Hintergründe des
raketeneinschlags gestern Florian du
hast uns jetzt schon mal die ersten
Informationen hier bekannt gegeben du
hast auch gerade schon gesagt dass du
damit rechnest das Stoltenberg auch
sagen wird dass die Einleitung der
Verfahren von Artikel 400 Artikel 5 wohl
vom Tisch sein was hast du vielleicht
darüber hinaus schon mitbekommen worum
es gleich in der Pressekonferenz gehen
wird und wie war sozusagen auch die
Stimmung und die Atmosphäre da heute vor
Ort in Brüssel
die Stimmung war natürlich schon gestern
Abend angespannt das war eine Meldung
auf die man wochenlang sozusagen vor dem
man sich gefürchtet hatte ein Szenario
das immer wieder mal im Raum stand was
wäre wenn es einen Angriff sei es auch
nur ein versehentlichen Angriff auf
nato-gebiet geben würde das war hier die
Gefahr die die Gefahr über die über
allem schwebte man wird heute und hat
auch heute bereits in der Sitzung wie
ich höre über die Frage gesprochen ob
man nun den Luft die Luftabwehr von
NATO-Staaten in Osteuropa verstärken
wird das hat etwa der slowakische
premier Eduard Heger vorab auch gesagt
der natürlich hat dieser Vorfall von
gestern noch mal allen verdeutlicht
dieser Krieg ist sehr nah an der NATO
und er ist weiterhin sehr gefährlich und
so ein Querschläger kann jederzeit
passieren und die Gefahr einer
Konfrontation zwischen den beiden
Blöcken NATO und Russland ist weiterhin
da und diese Konfrontation das sagte ich
ja bereits die will man auf nato-seiten
auf jeden Fall vermeiden man ist zwar
einerseits Partei insofern als man die
Ukraine stark unterstützt eben mit
Waffen militärisch und politisch und
wirtschaftlich man will aber keineswegs
direkte Kriegspartei werden und etwa mit
NATO-Truppen auf dem Boden der Ukraine
aktiv werden Dankeschön Florian neue
Hahn für diese Informationen aus Brüssel
und wir schauen jetzt gemeinsam mit
Natalie Steeger auf die Ereignisse von
gestern zum Raketeneinschlag in Polen
und den aktuellen Stand der Dinge den
fasste jetzt noch einmal für uns
zusammen
die Spurensuche geht mit Hochdruck
weiter in Polen das Gebiet bei
peschewurf an der Grenze zu Ukraine auch
am Morgen abgesperrt hier war der
Raketeneinschlag zwei tote die ganze
Nacht davor Krisen Treffen in Warschau
als erstes haben wir beschlossen die
Gefechtsbereitschaft ausgewählter Teile
der polnischen Streitkräfte zu erhöhen
mit besonderer Berücksichtigung der
Überwachung des Luftraums
gestern das was Polen seit Monaten
fürchtet Raketeneinschlag im eigenen
Land zeitgleich zu massiven russischen
Angriffen im Nachbarland Ukraine nach
polnischen Angaben handelt es sich
höchstwahrscheinlich um eine Rakete aus
russischer Produktion wer sie
abgeschossen hat ist noch offen aus
us-reisen heißt es es könne sich um eine
Rakete der ukrainischen flugabwehrhandel
wir können sagen was passiert ist war
ein einmaliger Vorfall nicht deutet
darauf hin dass weitere Folgen Polens
Präsident und die Regierung rufen
eindringlich dazu auf ruhig zu bleiben
nicht zu spekulieren Warschau reagiert
ausgesprochen besonnen man will sich eng
mit den NATO-Partnern konzertieren zur
Stunde weitere Krisensitzungen in
Warschau nicht nur Polen wartet auf neue
Erkenntnisse
was wir wissen und was wir nicht wissen
über den Raketen Einschlag in Polen das
können wir jetzt noch mal weiter
sortieren mit Markus Kolben die Experte
und Dozent an der Militärakademie der
ETA in Zürich hallo Herr grüße sie hallo
dann bleiben wir noch mal bei der Frage
wer hat diese Rakete abgefeuert da haben
wir jetzt die weiteren Informationen und
Aussagen gehört Joe Biden spricht davon
dass es unwahrscheinlich sei dass es
sich um eine laut Flugbahn um eine
russische Abfeuerung handelt sondern um
eine ukrainische Luft wäre abwehrrakete
auch Polens Präsident du da er sagt kein
gezielter Angriff sondern ein
unglücklicher Unfall was sind ihre
Informationen darüber wer diese Rakete
abgefeuert hat
also ich denke man kann mit stand 12 Uhr
zwei Dinge sagen zum einen es ist kein
gezielter Angriff Russlands auf NATO
Territorium soweit die Informationen die
ich habe das andere was man aber sicher
sagen kann ist dass diese ganze Episode
zusammenhängt mit dem russischen Raketen
Beschuss auf die Ukraine also
insbesondere mit dem Kriegsverbrechen
den dieser Beschuss darstellt es sind
eigentlich zwei narrative denkbar
entweder ist es eine fehlgeleitete
russische Rakete aus diesem Beschuss die
also ihr Ziel verfehlt hat und hinter
der Grenze in Polen eingeschlagen ist in
Wirklichkeit aber eine ukrainische Stadt
oder Ortschaft oder Energieinfrastruktur
treffen sollte das ist die eine
Möglichkeit das halte ich für die
weniger wahrscheinlicher etwas
wahrscheinlicher ist dass es
tatsächlich eine der Rest sozusagen eine
ukrainischen Flugabwehrrakete ist die
eine russische Rakete getroffen hat also
von der von ihrer Flugbahn abgelenkt hat
und dann selbst auf diesem polnischen
Gebiet abgestürzt ist das ist auch das
was die amerikanische Abwehr heute
morgen verbreitet hat also ich denke
eine bewussten Kriegsakt Russlands
können wir ausschließen das endet aber
natürlich nichts an der verbrecherischen
Natur dieser Angriffe durch russische
Raketen auf der ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung und vor allem die
Energieinfrastruktur ja absolut kleine
Ergänzung auch noch von der belgischen
Verteidigungsministerin auch sie spricht
am Morgen davon dass die Einschläge
Zitat von ukrainischen
luftabwehrsystemen ausgelöst worden sein
sollen die zur Abwehr russischer Raketen
eingesetzt wurden also genau das was sie
auch beschrieben haben und was sie auch
noch hinzugefügt hat ist auf Grundlage
der verfügbaren Informationen sein Zitat
Trümmerteile von russischen Raketen und
ukrainischen Flugabwehrraketen auf
polnischen Boden eingeschlagen auch
Informationen die Sie haben ja dann das
ist eigentlich der wahrscheinlichste
Fall den ich mir hier zusammen
konstruiert habe nach den Daten die mir
vorliegen das wäre also tatsächlich so
ein intercept nach dem Motto die
russische Rakete fliegt an die Ukraine
können Sie abfangen also sprich die
Raketen kollidieren in der Luft und die
Trümmerteile beide Raketen stürzen dann
unkontrolliert an
jetzt geht es natürlich auch noch um die
Frage was ist das für ein Typ Rakete
gewesen
abwehrrakete Joe Biden soll sich am
Rande des G20 Gipfels auch geäußert
haben und dort von einem Typ S300
gesprochen haben so heißt es und jetzt
auch der polnische Präsident Du da in
seiner Erklärung spricht auch dass es am
wahrscheinlichsten sei dass die Rakete
vom Typ S300 ist was sind da ihre
Informationen und was ist das für ein
Typ Rakete dann
also ich habe noch keine konkreten
Informationen über den Typ Rakete ich
würde auch vorsichtig damit sein bis wir
eindeutige virus bekommen also bis wir
klare Fotografien haben der IDS jede
Messer lässt sich eindeutig
identifizieren anhand einer Idee die auf
dem auf dem Hülle sich befindet das
heißt man kann dann sehr genau sagen was
für eine Metall ist es und welches
System hat sie abgeschossen das Problem
in diesem Krieg ist nun eben das sowohl
die Ukraine als auch Russland Ex
sowjetische Waffensysteme verwenden das
heißt also sowohl Russland die auch die
Ukraine haben S300 der Luftabwehrsysteme
das heißt man kann nicht immer so
eindeutig sagen von von wem kam das
jetzt oder aus welchem System wurde das
abgeschossen deswegen würde ich auch
hier etwas zur Zurückhaltung warten
warten bis wir visual confirmation haben
von der missile ID und dann könnte man
das mit größerer Sicherheit sagen also
ganz klarer Zusammenfassung das wissen
wir eben noch nicht gesichert um welchen
Typ es sich handelt da warten wir auf
die weiteren Untersuchungen und werden
das dann gegebenenfalls nachreichen Herr
Kolb sind gerade schon die
wahrscheinlichen Szenarien skizziert
vielleicht machen wir es noch mal
konkret eine Frage die sich ja auch
stellt wie konnte das denn dann jetzt
überhaupt passieren vielleicht können
wir das noch einmal ausführen
ja wie konnte es passieren das müssen
sie eigentlich die Russen Fragen die
ständig Raketen abschießen auf die
ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung naja wir
haben das Muster ja schon in der
Vergangenheit gesehen jedes Mal wenn die
russische Armee eine Niederlage erleidet
oder sich zurückziehen muss dann kommt
sozusagen der Racheakt plus der zivilen
Infrastruktur das haben wir jetzt schon
mehrfach gesehen und sie haben ja selbst
ausführlich berichtet über den Abzug der
Russen aus der Sonne und die Befreiung
ist besetzten Gebietes am rechten Ufer
des Körper und wir können jetzt annehmen
dass das sozusagen wieder die die Rache
ist für diese Niederlage es ändert
natürlich nichts am militärischen
Kriegsverlauf aber je mehr die Russen zu
dieser Taktik greifen desto mehr ist es
eben nicht mehr nur sozusagen ein
einfaches Kriegsverbrechen sondern es
geht dann wirklich in Richtung genutzt
also wenn man systematisch die
Lebensgrundlagen der Bevölkerung
zerstört dann sind wir also schon über
Artikel 22 23 der Hagel antriebsordnung
weit hinaus
dann müssen wir uns tatsächlich mit
Genozid befassen ich bin in der
Vergangenheit immer sehr vorsichtig
gewesen mit diesem Schlagwort aber die
systematische Zerstörung der
Lebensgrundlagen eines Volkes
qualifiziert diesen Tatbestand und ich
denke der Strafgerichtshof in Den Haag
wird noch sehr sehr viel zu tun bekommen
absolut wir hören gerade aus Brüssel
dass sich die Pressekonferenz mit
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg etwas
verzögern wird das gibt uns die Zeit und
den Raum noch mal zusammenzufassen was
wir wissen und was wir nicht wissen und
es gibt uns auch die Zeit auf eure
Fragen Liebe Userinnen und User zu
schauen eine Herr Koll würde ich Ihnen
ganz gerne direkt Weiterleiten von
Julian bei Youtube der fragt sind an der
polnisch ukrainischen Grenze keine
Flugabwehrsysteme der NATO installiert
die diese Rakete hätten abfangen können
also das muss man etwas differenziert
betrachten also selbstverständlich gibt
es erste Wählens also
luftradar also zur Beobachtung und
natürlich auch Luftabwehrsysteme also in
Lagune zum Beispiel das ist ein
polnisches ein polnische Ortschaft etwa
40 km weg von dort steht ein großes
Wellens Radar und äh natürlich auch am
Flughafen von jazzoff über den Teile der
westlichen Waffenlieferungen
hineinkommen steht ein Patrick
Abwehrsystem der USA nun ist es aber
natürlich so dass dieses Systeme passiv
den Raum beobachten ja Sie dürfen sich
also nicht so vorstellen dass sie quasi
die den den gesamten Luftraum komplett
perfekt schützen können gegen jedes
anfliegende Objekt sondern man schaut
eher wie ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
Russland jetzt tatsächlich in größerem
Umfang einen strategischen Schlag auf
Polen also in dem Fall auf Südost Polen
vorbereiten würde und das ist nicht der
Fall ähm es ist aber nicht so dass man
quasi nicht sehen würde was die Russen
da machen und ich denke das ist ein ganz
wichtiges Thema für den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf nämlich die
ja die die Ausstattung der Ukraine mit
mit deutlich mehr Erde fansmitteln also
mit luftverteidigungsmitteln als bisher
geschehen nur können Sie das eben nicht
direkt machen indem man natuland quasi
inaktiv in diese Luftverteidigung
eingreift deswegen ist das nicht so
leicht zu sagen ja wir nehmen jetzt die
Systeme die in Polen stehen und dann
schützen wir damit die Ukraine weil das
würde tatsächlich Polen gefährlich nah
in die Rolle einer Kriegspartei
bringen was man aber natürlich tun kann
und ich denke die Amerikaner denken da
im Moment drüber nach ist einfach jetzt
Raketenabwehr in die Ukraine zu liefern
und natürlich auch die Deutschen die ja
sehr beliebt sind in letzter Zeit weil
die Iris tslm so gut funktioniert auch
die könnten sich überlegen das gleiche
zu tun
genau das wäre jetzt auch meine
Anschlussfrage gewesen was man denn dann
anstelle dessen gemacht haben könnte das
haben sie gerade schon ausgeführt vielen
Dank wir hören gerade das in gut einer
Minute die Pressekonferenz beginnen soll
gibt uns noch mal die Möglichkeit eine
weitere Frage reinzugehen die geht ein
bisschen ins Detail von Pro Europa die
Frage an Sie Herr Kolb ist dieser
Raketeneinschlag eventuell ein
Wendepunkt für die westliche
waffenexportpolitik in Klammern
Langstrecken
Ars Munition Leo 2 etc das ist eine
Frage
nein ich denke nicht also ähm wir reden
hier was diesen Einschlag angeht sehr
stark über Luftabwehr je stärker die
ukrainische Luftabwehr ist desto weniger
wahrscheinlich ist es dass solche
Szenarien sich wiederholen werden die
Frage Panzer die stellt sich hier für
dieses Problem nicht die stellt sich
aber natürlich dann für den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf
ein Kommentar auch noch von Kai Nord auf
Facebook der kommt von euch rein der
fast das ganze wie sieht es beschrieben
haben Herr Kolb auch noch mal zusammen
letztlich mag es jetzt in diesem Fall
sein das Russland nichts mit dem
Einschlag zu tun hat aber trotzdem sind
sie mitverantwortlich weil sie diesen
Krieg führen und ohne diesen Krieg hätte
ist diesen Einschlag auch nicht gegeben
auch wenn das Zitat so mancher nicht in
seine Birne bekommt dass die
Zusammenfassung von kein Nord auf
Facebook Zusammenfassung mit der sie
auch mitgehen oder das ist völlig
korrekt und ich gratuliere dem User hat
das wirklich sehr sehr schön
zusammengefasst
noch beginnt die Pressekonferenz nicht
in Brüssel mit Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg gibt uns aber die
Möglichkeit vielleicht doch noch mal
zusammenzufassen für diejenigen oder
derjenigen die jetzt gerade erst frisch
in den Stream dazu gekommen sind was
wissen wir bisher über diesen
Raketeneinschlag und was noch nicht ja
also was wir definitiv wissen ist es ist
keine bewusste russische kriegerische
Aktion gegen NATO Territorium es ist
vielmehr das Resultat der Luftabwehr die
sich aus dem gestrigen Raketenbeschuss
Russlands ergeben hat das heißt also wir
haben im Prinzip zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder ist es eine fehlgeleitete
russische Rakete die also ein
ukrainisches Ziel treffen sollte und
direkt in Polen kurz hinter der Grenze
eingeschlagen ist das ist ähm etwas
unwahrscheinlich im Moment nach dem
neuesten Daten wahrscheinlicher ist dass
es eine erfolgreiche ukrainische
Luftabwehr war also eine
Flugabwehrrakete der Ukraine die diese
Rakete getroffen hat und und Reste
vermutlich mit den Resten der russischen
Rakete kurz hinter der Grenze in Polen
eingeschlagen sind das heißt also wie es
ist nicht der Fall dass hier Artikel 4
oder Artikel 5 des NATO-Vertrages
ausgerufen würde sie haben das kurz an
diskutiert dass der Stream losgehen da
wollte ich noch kurz ergänzen
tatsächlich haben sich in Polen also in
diesem Südost polnischen Raum gestern
die leitungsstäbe der Feuerwehr und der
Zivilverteidigung getroffen einfach um
quasi in diesem Raum zu schauen was was
war da eigentlich los und das haben auf
Twitter manche viel interpretiert dass
das jetzt schon quasi die Krisensitzung
der polnischen Regierung gewesen sei die
in der Nacht angeblich stattgefunden
hätte hätte
sie wissen ja twitter ist immer
furchtbar aufgeregt aber es bietet sich
an in solchen bei solchen Dingen immer
etwas ruhig zu bleiben und erstmal
abzubauen also da dann auch noch mal von
ihnen also die Einschätzung dass dem
nicht so war
nein also ich jedenfalls liegen mir
keine entsprechenden Daten vor ich weiß
auch von keiner Krisensitzung der
polnischen Regierung bislang ja super
danke für die Klarstellung und eine
user-frage kommt auch rein von crumble
GEA er fragt inwiefern würde es jetzt
Sinn machen den Luftraum bis Lemberg zu
schließen eventuell als Gegenmaßnahme
den Luftraum zu schließen ist im Prinzip
eine gute Idee nur lässt sich das
technisch nicht so einfach
bewerkstelligen sie müssen ja sich
vorstellen pro eher defence Batterien
können Sie nur entweder einen begrenzten
Ausschnitt des Himmels abdecken oder ein
bestimmtes Objekt schützen das heißt
wenn ihr Ziel ist den kompletten
Luftraum zu schließen dann ist das mit
stationärer er Defense schwer möglich da
werden wir wirklich in der Welt des
Kalten Krieges wo sie permanente
Einsatzbereitschaft brauchen und wo die
Erde Fans auch aus verschiedenen
Effektoren kommt das heißt also sie
kommt sowohl Boden Luft als auch Luft
Luft das heißt sie bräuchten dann
ständig Kampfflugzeuge in der Luft die
den Raum entsprechend passiv überwachen
und dann mit mitsamt dafür hat die
Ukraine nicht die luftmittel im Moment
das ist ein Grund übrigens warum die
Ukraine immer wieder nach luftmitteln
gebeten hat den Westen es ist möglich
dass das jetzt vielleicht wieder zu
solchen politischen Diskussionen führt
also sprich sollte die Ukraine Flugzeuge
bekommen sozusagen abgerüstete
Kampfflugzeuge die in der Lage sind nur
Luftverteidigung zu machen das ist dann
eine Frage die die die
Luftwaffen produzierenden Länder im
Wesentlichen
beantworten müssen vor allem die USA
Herr Kolb wir hören gerade dass die
Pressekonferenz mit Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg losgeht und da hören wir
jetzt direkt rein alles klar
noch haben wir wie ich sehe und höre
kein Bild aus Brüssel von der
Pressekonferenz jetzt können wir aber
übergehen und da hören wir ernst-
als Russland eine umfassende Welle von
Raketenangriffen auf die Ukraine begann
seitdem Anfang des undichtmäßigen
Krieges Russlands in der Ukraine hat die
NATO ihre wachtsamkeit an der Ostflanke
verstärkt wie überwachen die Situation
laufend
Vorfall sind im Gange und wir müssen auf
das Ergebnis warten
wir haben allerdings keinen Hinweis
darauf dass es sich hier um einen
bewussten Angriff gehandelt hatte
nichts dort darauf hin dass Russland
militärische Angriffs-
unsere vorläufige Analyse lässt darauf
schließen dass der Zwischenfall
wahrscheinlich
von einer Rakete der ukrainischen
Luftabwehr verursacht wurde die
abgeschossen wurde um russische
barschflugkörper im Angriff auf die
Ukraine abzuwehren aber ich möchte
deutlich machen das ist nicht das
Verschulden der Ukraine
trägt letztendlich die Verantwortung da
das Land den unrechtmäßigen Krieg gegen
die Ukraine immer weiter fortsetzt
der heutigen Sitzung haben die NATO
Verbündeten ihr Beileid zu dem Verlust
von Menschenleben aus gedrückt und ihre
starke Solidarität mit unserem
geschätzten Bündnispartner pullen
bekundet
wir haben verdeutlicht dass wir die
Ukraine weiterhin bei ihrem Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung unterstützen werden
Russland muss diesen sinnlosen Krieg
beenden
gestern Abend habe ich mit dem
polnischen Präsidenten und US-Präsident
Joe Biden gesprochen wir haben uns
darauf verständigt dass wir die
Wachsamkeit aufrechterhalten werden und
in enger Koordinierung Verfahren werden
die werden uns weiter beraten und die
Lage genau beobachten
ist geschlossen und wir werden stets das
nötige tun um alle Verbündeten zu
schützen und zu verteidigen nun nehme
ich gerne Fragen entgegen
der polnische Hund von bitte die Dame
dort hinten
was könnte das konkrete Ergebnis der
heutigen Sitzung sein könnte man die
Luftabwehr in Europa verstärken gerade
in den an die Ukraine angrenzenden
Staaten es wird ja doch wohl
möglicherweise wieder vorkommen dass
ukrainische Städte von russischen
Raketen getroffen werden und dann könnte
ein Vorfall wie gestern erneut passieren
Verbündeten haben gestern ihre deutliche
Unterstützung bekundet
für unseren Verbündeten Polen wir haben
unser Beileid ausgesprochen für den
Verlust von Menschen leben und die Nato
hat ihre Präsenz im östlichen Teil der
Allianz weiter ausgebaut insbesondere
seit dem Überfall auf die Ukraine im
Februar
wir haben mehr Bodentruppen dort
stationiert aber außerdem auch
sehr viel Luft und parietigkeit Kräfte
eingesetzt damit haben wir unsere
luftabwehrfähigkeiten verbessert aber
auch unsere Möglichkeiten
Überwachungsmaßnahmen vorzunehmen
damit wir ein umfassendes Bild von den
Abläufen an der Grenze bekommen können
an der Grenze zwischen denen Verbündeten
wie Polen und der Ukraine
wir bewirten ständig was noch an
weiteren Maßnahmen nötig wird wir haben
auf unserem Gipfel in Madrid wichtige
Entscheidung getroffen um unsere Präsenz
in den östlichen Teil des Bündnisses
auszubauen
liebe sie bitte
danke
ich habe folgende Frage nach dem Vorfall
von gestern Abend
war das vielleicht der
angespannteste Augenblick für die NATO
bisher in diesem Konflikt
ich bin immer vorsichtig jetzt eine
Rangfolge
auszusprechen was am wichtigsten ist und
was nicht jedenfalls sehen wir dass der
Krieg in der Ukraine für den Präsident
Verantwortung trägt weiterhin
gefährliche Situationen heraufbeschwört
wir müssen daran denken dass dies ja
gleichzeitig passiert ist während
Russland eine ganze Angriffswelle
gestartet hat
wahllos Raketen auf ukrainische Städte
abgeschossen hat mit Angriffen auf die
entscheidend wichtige zivile
Infrastruktur auf zivile
allein ist schon eine sehr gefährliche
Situation
und darüber hinaus erleben wir ja auch
das ist weitere Folgen auf nato-gebiet
geben kann in Folge des Krieges den
Russland begonnen hat und den Russland
weiterhin gegen die Ukraine führt
die ukrainische Nachrichtenagentur dort
binden bitte
unterstreichen dass die Ukraine
die Trauer in Polen versteht und sehr
viel Mitgefühl empfinden ich möchte
fragen wie sich dieser Vorfall auswirkt
auf die Unterstützung der Verbündeten
für die Ukraine bei der
Luftabwehrsysteme kommen um den
ukrainischen Himmel abzudecken
in der es wird heute noch eine Sitzung
geben in der Kontaktgruppe mit der
Ukraine
dort wird die Unterstützung durch die
NATO Verbündeten durch die verschiedenen
Partner
abgesprochen die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine und der
Hauptschwerpunkt in den letzten Monaten
hat ja bei der Luftabwehr gelegen gerade
auch seit diesem wahllosen Angriffen
Russlands auf ukrainische Städte seit
einigen Wochen
ich begrüße es dass immer mehr
Verbündete und Partner fortgeschrittene
Luftabwehrsysteme für die Ukraine
bereitstellen
auf Spanien und anderen Staaten und ich
weiß auch dass Schweden neue Lieferungen
mitgeteilt hat weitere Unterstützung
auch im luftabwehrbereich aus Schweden
für die Ukraine da wird also viel
mobilisiert weitere Unterstützung kommt
gerade auch bei den verschiedenen Formen
von luftabwehrsystemen
[Musik]
und so weiter bereit zu stellen die
brauchen eine entsprechende Verteidigung
der Ukraine daran arbeiten wir und genau
das liefern unsere vermuteten auch in
unterschiedliche Form
bitte
darf ich aber fragen ob dieser Vorfall
bedeutet dass mehr Luftabwehr für die
Verbündeten an der OST Grenze aufgebaut
wird im Vergleich zum Anfang des Krieges
musste noch mehr geschehen
[Musik]
die Lage und unsere Präsenz im östlichen
tagesbündnisses laufend wir haben unsere
Präsenz am Boden in der Luft und auf sie
ständig ausgeweitet und damit auch
unsere luftabwehrfähigkeiten gerade im
Ostteil des Bündnisses erweitert
gleichzeitig deutet nichts darauf hin
dass dieser Vorfall ein bewusster
Angriff auf nato-gebiet war
daraufhin dass Russland irgendwie Pläne
hat
militärische Angriffshandlungen
vorzunehmen gegen Natur Verbündete
das zeigt jedenfalls aber die Gefahren
die mit dem Laufenden Krieg in der
Ukraine verbunden sind unsere
grundlegende Wirkung ändert sich dadurch
in Bezug auf die Bedrohung von NATO
Verbündeten wir erkennen die Bedeutung
der Überwachung
der Wachsamkeit der Präsenz und wir
haben für eine langfristige Anpassung
der nato-abwehr schon in Madrid auf dem
Gipfel im Juni
vorbereitet und das umfasst zum Teil
sehr Präsenz im Osten zum Teil Bier vor
abstationierte Ausrüstungen im Ostteil
des Bündnisses und zum Teil auch weitere
Streitkräfte die unsere battlegroups
unsere Kampfgruppen im Ostteil des
Bündnisses verstärken können daneben
auch Ausbau unserer Luft Abwehr die
Luftabwehr erfolgt zum Teil vom Boden
aus aber auch von Flugzeugen aus
und teilweise auch von Schiffen
können wir schnell in die Nähe bringen
entsprechend den Vorstellungen unseres
Oberkommandierenden in Europa sie hat
alle Möglichkeiten auch die Marine und
die Luftwaffen
vorbei
Fahrt oder fliegen zu lassen damit es
schnell gehandelt werden kann
danke
in
polenische
abwehrrakete die eine russische Rakete
abfangen wollte oder waren da auch
Trümmer eine russischen Rakete dabei und
wie sah die wahrscheinliche Flugbahn der
russischen Rakete aus die von der
Ukraine abgefangen werden sollte und
drittenseitkräfte an der Ostflanke ihre
Luftabwehrsysteme gestern aktiviert weil
sie eine
potenziell anfliegende Rakete entdeckt
hatten
systems in place wir haben dort
Luftabwehrsysteme die aktiv geschaltet
sind Tag und Nacht ständig im Einsatz
ständig in der Überwachung wir haben
E-Bikes überwachungsflugzeuge wir haben
andere Flugzeuge die diese Aufgabe
übernehmen wir haben
landgestützte Systeme und sägestützte
Systeme
wir haben also eine Luftabwehr die
ständig im Einsatz ist überall im
Bündnis daneben legen wir auch ein
weiteren Schwerpunkt
seit einiger Zeit auf den Ostteil des
Bündnisses und Pool gehört bekanntlich
dazu
was dann die Erkenntnisse der laufende
der Ermittlungen anbelangt
wichtig wenn ich diese Einzelheiten
jetzt vortrüge
ich habe aber darauf hingewiesen dass
unsere vorläufigen Ergebnisse dahin
deuten
dass es sich wahrscheinlich um
Erde Fans mich soll eine ukrainische
Luftabwehrrakete gehandelt hat nichts
weist darauf hin dass es sich um ein
bewussten Angriff auf Natel Gebiet
gehandelt hat
eine kurze Frage
hat es irgendein Kontakt zwischen der
Nato die russischen Behörden gegeben man
sieht auch auf der technischen Ebene den
letzten 24 Stunden in Bezug auf die
russischen Aktivitäten in der Nähe der
NATO
Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten
unterschiedliche Art mit Russland als
NATO als Verbündete aber die
Einzelheiten kann ich hier nicht
ansprechen was in den letzten 24 Stunden
geschehen ist
Deutsche Welle
die polnische Regierung auch nach
stundenlanger Bewirtung des Vorgangs
heute morgen immer noch Beratungen nach
Artikel 4 verlangt hat Leute das darauf
hin dass man dort in Polen nicht so
sicher ist ob die Begriff den Maßnahmen
ausreichen
ja alles laufen sagen sie machen die mit
sehr Planer denn weitere Überlegungen im
Augenblick mehr nach Polen zu schicken
um dort für mehr Sicherheit wie ein
größeres Sicherheitsgefühl zu sorgen das
ist ja doch Artikel 4 der dort
angesprochen worden ist auch im Zuge der
Ermittlungen
ich habe gestern Abend mit Präsident
Julia gesprochen wir waren uns darüber
einig dass es in dieser Lage wichtig ist
erst einmal die Ermittlungsergebnisse
abzuwarten das Endergebnis die laufenden
Ermittlungen liegt noch nicht vor aber
der Verbündeten sind sich alle über die
von mir gerade vorgetragenen Bewertung
einig nichts Leute das einen bewussten
Angriff hin und das hat natürlich dann
auch Folgen für die Reaktion die wir
zeigen müssen
also keine vorsätzlicher Angriff war und
wenn Russland keine militärischen Aktion
gegen dafür Verbündete zu planen scheint
wir sind uns aber auch darüber einig
dass letztlich Russland die
Verantwortung trägt dort ist man für den
Krieg verantwortlich den der Ukraine
geführt wird
der Krieg hat diese Situation erst dabei
geführt
dich gegeben hätte dann hätten sich
diese beiden Todesopfer in Polen gehabt
auch nicht den Vorgang der gestern in
Polen sich zugetragen hat
Verbündeten sind sich über den Ansatz
nötig was Artikel 4 angeht und das
beruht auf den Erkenntnissen der Analyse
und den Ergebnissen der bisher laufenden
Ermittlungen
der Spiegel
alles getan um die Verbündeten zu
schützen
das Dorf das gestern von der Rakete
getroffen wurde war dicht an der
ukrainischen Grenze und Polen vor
solchen Vorfällen künftig zu schützen
wäre es gar nicht sinnvoll und denkbar
aus ihrer Sicht
die NATO
Abwehr den abwehrfilm der NATO in Polen
auszuweiten um auch Raketen abzufangen
die potenzielle Ziele in der Nähe der
ukrainischen Grenze bei Polen erreichen
könnten
die naturpartner sind kein Teil des
Konflikts in der Ukraine die NATO
Verbündeten unterstützen die Ukraine es
geht um das Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
der Ukraine das ist in der uno-kater
verankert und die Ukraine hat also das
Recht sich gegen den illegalen Krieg
Russlands in Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine zu verteidigen unsere wichtigste
Universität besteht nun darin Bier
Luftabwehrsysteme für die Ukraine
bereitzustellen
unsere
luftabwehrdisthebe sind dazu da vor
Angriffen rund um die Uhr zu schützen
ist weist aber nichts darauf hin dass es
sich über ein bewussten Angriff
gehandelt hat und dieser Vorfall
weist also nicht die Merkmale eines
Angriffs auf das erklärt auch weshalb
die Reaktion so ausgefallen sind wie es
gestern Abend der Fall war
wie gesagt kein bewusster Angriff und
dementsprechend auch kein Angriff auf
nato-gebiet
eine eher persönliche Frage
viel Angst und dachten froh das könnte
eine gefährliche Situation geben wir
haben Sie persönlich reagiert als sie
erstmals die Nachricht bekam gestern
Abend dann haben sie gesagt Trümmer sind
gefunden worden wahrscheinlich von einer
ukrainischen Luft ab wie Rakete der
ukraineische
Außenminister hatte von Android
russischen Verschwörung gesprochen das
stimme nicht die könnt ihr das
beurteilen
die letzte Frage
gesagt das ist eine russische
Verschwörungstheorie dass Sie sich über
die russische Luft eine ukrainische Luft
abwehrrakete gehandelt habe ihre ersten
Ergebnisse sind anscheinend ganz anders
nur die Ermittlungen sind noch nicht
abgeschlossen aber nach dem was wir
bisher wissen ist es
schon so dass es sich wahrscheinlich um
eine ukrainische Luft Abwehrsysteme
abwehrrakete eines Abwehrsystems der
Ukraine gehandelt hat aber das ist nicht
die Schuld der Ukraine Russland trägt
die Verantwortung dafür dass dies
gestern in Polen sich so zugetragen hat
das ist die direkte Folge des laufenden
Krieges gegen die Ukraine eine ganze
Angriffswelle ist ja von Russland
gestern gegen die Ukraine
durchgeführt worden und die Ukraine hat
das Recht solche Raketen abzuschießen
die auf ukrainische Städte abzielen und
die kritische
Infrastruktur dort zerstören sollen denn
folgendes sagen die NATO ist auf solche
Situationen vorbereitet wir haben unsere
Übungen unsere Vorbereitungen auch für
dieartige Vorfälle damit wir zuerst
einmal
vorbeugend tätig werden können aber wenn
es dann doch dazu kommt darf das ganze
Licht außer Kontrolle geraten natürlich
wir haben uns Sorgen gemacht als wir
gestern die Meldung bekam
und vor allem
waren wir betrübt über die beiden
Todesopfer
aber gleichzeitig überwachen wir auch
die Lage
und wir sind bereit mit solchen
Situationen umzugehen wir sind
entschieden ruhig und entschlossen dabei
handelt aber auch auf eine Art und Weise
die eine weitere Eskalation ausschließen
soll
sie haben wiederholt erklärt die NATO
habe alle Fähigkeiten
hier entsprechend zu handeln und sie
seien auf solche Vorfälle jederzeit
vorbereitet war das jetzt ein Fehler der
nato-abwehr dass diese Rakete auf
polnischen Gebiet gelandet ist
nun Luftabwehrsysteme sind dazu da uns
vor Angriffen zu
schützenkörper oder belästische Raketen
haben bestimmte Merkmale
wir überwachen das anfliegende Gerät den
Flugkörper und dann fragen wir uns was
ist das worum geht es und sie sagten uns
wahrscheinlich
eine ukrainische luft-
sagt nichts über unsere Fähigkeit aus
uns gegen bewusste Angriffe auf
nathe-gebiet zu verteidigen
noch einige Sachfragen wenn es geht
wissen wie schon ob es eine russische
Rakete in unmittelbarer Nähe gegeben hat
die von den Ukrainern gezielt
angepeilt worden ist und wenn die
ukrainische Rakete exportiert ist am
Boden oder in der Luft hat es da einen
Kontakt mit einer russischen Rakete
gegeben oder sind meinetwegen nur
Trümmer der ukrainische Rakete zu Boden
gefahren
[Musik]
sind berechtigt aber Einzelheiten kann
ich die nicht ansprechen zum Teil auch
deshalb weil die Ermittlungen noch nicht
abgeschlossen sind
[Musik]
später dann darüber entscheiden welche
Einzelheiten bekannt gegeben werden
jedenfalls laufen die Ermittlungen und
wir sehen uns das alles genau an
hat jetzt verlangt
hier müssen wir an Vermittlung
stattfinden vor allem durch China sollte
China hier vermitteln und sehen Sie
irgendeine Möglichkeit für
Friedensverhandlungen Zukunft
die Invasion den Überfall auf die
Ukraine verurteilen sollte das ist eine
plakante Verletzung des Völkerrechts und
der Souveränität durch eine integrierte
Ukraine
Gremien bei den Abstimmungen
hat China die Infusion nicht eindeutig
verurteilt China
die russische Erzählung über diesen
Krieg das stimmt nicht das beschreibt
die Verhältnisse nicht richtig Russland
Präsident Putin sind für den Krieg
Verantwortlichen müssen den Krieg
beenden
was das ist dies ist ein Angriffskrieg
wo ein Land Russland ein anderes Land
angreift und diesem landgebietsteile
wegnehmen will
die Ukraine hat das Recht sich dagegen
zu verteidigen gegen den Überfall gegen
die russische Aggression
und die Ukraine das Kämpfen einstellen
dann wird Russland natürlich gewinnen
und die militärischen Ziele erreichen
die Realität sieht also so aus wenn
Russland bin Präsident Putin mit dem
Kämpfen aufhört dann haben wir den
Frieden bin aber Präsidenten und Ukraine
mit dem Kämpfen aufhören dann gibt es
die Ukraine nicht mehr als unabhängiger
Staat dort hat das Recht sich als
unabhängige Stadt selbst zu verteidigen
wahrscheinlich wird dieser Krieg
irgendwann am Verhandlungstisch enden
wir dass der Ausgang der Verhandlungen
grundlegend und sehr eng mit der Stärke
auf dem Gefechtsfeld zusammenhängt
die beste Möglichkeit also für uns dafür
zu sorgen
das ist eine friedliche
Verhandlungslösung gibt besteht darin
die Ukraine auf den Gefechtsfeld zu
unterstützen denn das wird es
wahrscheinlicher machen dass die Ukraine
eine hinnehmbare Verhandlungslösung
erreicht die wollen alle den Frieden
natürlich wollen wir alle so dass dieser
Krieg aufhört aber das ist die beste
Möglichkeit für einen Frieden
beizutragen der dafür sorgt dass die
Ukraine als unabhängiger Stadt erhalten
bleibt wir müssen die Kredit dafür
militärisch unterstützen der bitte seine
annehmbare Verhandlungslösung geben kann
noch eine letzte Frage aus Polen bitte
gesagt es ist zu früh zu sagen ob das
ein Unfall war oder was auch immer aber
das war doch auch ein Stresstest für die
ganze NATO können Sie das Bewerten und
etwas zu Reaktion der polnische
Regierung zu den rotationskanälen und
die Reaktion der NATO sagen kann da noch
etwas verbessert werden kann man etwas
für die Zukunft lernen
die NATO Verbündeten und Polen haben
kühl gemessen und koordiniert reagiert
wir haben uns abgestimmt haben
koordiniert gehandelt wir haben
natürlich gestern Abend immer wieder
miteinander gesprochen und auch die
militärischen Kommandeure haben uns
informiert ich habe mit die
Oberbefehlshaber der NATO gestern Abend
und heute morgen gesprochen und er war
auch hier heute morgen
für einen Briefing bei den Verbündeten
wir haben also ein
Informationsaustausch gehabt mit
gemessenen Reaktionen und mit der
Aussage dass wir die Fakten klären
müssen bevor wir endgültige
Schlussfolgerung ziehen können über den
Vorfall in Polen
das macht doch deutlich dass die NATO
Verbündeten vorsichtig und
verantwortungsbewusst gehandelt haben
müssen verstehen wenn man mit einem
solchen Vorfall umgehen will dann geht
es zum einen und Festigkeit und schnelle
Reaktion zum anderen aber auch um Ruhe
Bedächtigkeit und die Verhinderung einer
unnötigen Eskalation dieses
Gleichgewicht müssen wir immer anstreben
und deshalb ist es
nötig ermöglicht genau das Bild der Lage
zu haben deshalb hatte ich gestern
gesagt wir müssten etwas Zeit haben und
uns das ganze anzuschauen das haben wir
im Laufe der Nacht getan und wir haben
jetzt ein klares Bild
ein Bild das zeigt dass nichts darauf
hindeutet dass es sich um ein bewussten
Angriff gehandelt hat
kein gezielter Angriff auf nato-gebiet
kein Hinweis darauf dass Russland
irgendwelche Angriffshandlungen außer
der Ukraine vorhat aber dieser Vorfall
als Ganzes wertverursacht durch den
brutalen Krieg Russlands in der Ukraine
die beste Möglichkeit künftig so etwas
zu unterbinden besteht darin dass
Russland den Krieg beendet danke schön
das also die komplette Pressekonferenz
von Nato-Generalsekretär Jens
Stoltenberg zu den Hintergründen und um
den Raketeneinschlag in Polen bei dem
zwei Menschen mindestens zwei Menschen
ums Leben gekommen sein sollen wir
können das jetzt noch mal weiter
vertiefen mit Markus Keup Militärexperte
bei uns im Stream und Dozent an der
Militärakademie der ETA in Zürich hallo
Herr Kolb ich fasse noch mal ganz kurz
die drei wichtigsten Aussagen von Herrn
Stoltenberg zusammen also es sei es dann
keine Hinweise bekannt dass es ein
bewusster Angriff Russlands auf die NATO
gewesen sei und ein zweiter er hat
natürlich da sein Beileid der NATO
Mitglieder und die Unterstützung an
Polen ausgerichtet und er hat auch noch
mal klar gemacht dass auch wenn es sich
um die ukrainische Luftabwehrrakete
handelt das hat der bestätigt dass
trotzdem Russland die Verantwortung
dafür trägt weil Russland den Krieg
führt wie sortieren Sie diese
Erkenntnisse wie ordnen sie ein und auch
den Auftritt von herrnberg
ja ich kann das genauso bestätigen das
deckt sich absolut mit meiner
Einschätzung ohne den russischen
Raketenbeschuss auf die Ukraine der im
übrigen völkerrechtswidrig und an der
Grenze zum Genozid ist wäre diese ganze
Episode nicht passiert und Sie sehen da
eben auch die Bedeutung der Ukraine wir
sagen jetzt immer so na ja das ist ja
alles da im Osten und das geht uns
nichts an oh doch es geht uns sehr wohl
an zweieinhalb Flugstunden sind sie da
und was was Stolberg ganz am Anfang
seiner Pressekonferenz erzählt hat ich
denke das ist so die die Richtung für
die Zukunft das jetzt nämlich
verschiedene Länder unter anderem
Schweden
beabsichtigen Ihre Lieferungen zur
ukrainischen Erde Fans aufzustocken und
genau das sollte man auch tun man muss
Russland hier klare Signale geben dass
diese Art der Taktik nicht aufgehen wird
sondern im Gegenteil dass sie nur weiter
dazu führen wird dass die Ukraine ihre
Verteidigung ausbaut es kann keine
Alternative geben zu diesem Ausgang des
Krieges also um Russland klar zu machen
mit dieser imperialen Politik die die
Grundlage unserer Staatenordnung nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg adapsurdum führen
will mit dieser imperialen Politik
kommst du nicht weiter es gilt nicht
mehr das Recht des Stärkeren sondern wir
haben rule of law unsere internationale
Ordnung basiert auf dem Völkerrecht und
wenn Russland das nicht freiwillig
anerkennen will dann wird man ihm in
diesem Krieg klarmachen müssen wo die
Grenze ist und da sollten wir ja auch
noch mal bestätigt dass es dazu zu
dieser Verstärkung der Luftabwehrsysteme
auch aus anderen Ländern heute noch eine
Sitzung mit der Kontaktgruppe der NATO
auch geben wird um das auch noch mal zu
besprechen die Frage kam ja auch von
einer ukrainischen
Nachrichtenagentur eine zweite Frage die
kam aus Deutschland die ging noch mal in
Richtung der Flugkurve also Richtung der
Frage wie konnte das passieren und da
haben wir auch eine user-frage von
Mister Greeny das würde ich jetzt noch
mal eben zusammen führen dass wir das
vielleicht noch mal erklären auch mit
den Aussagen von Herrn Stoltenberg wie
kann denn so eine Rakete so vom Kurs
abkommen
naja was sie können sich das ganz
einfach vorstellen die feindliche Rakete
fliegt an und will ein bestimmtes Ziel
treffen die ukrainische abwehrrakete
steigt auf und trifft diese Rakete das
heißt es gibt zunächst eine Explosion in
der Luft damit ist die Flugabwehrrakete
sozusagen erledigt das heißt deren
Treibstoff Entschuldigung Sprengstoff
ist explodiert und ihre Trümmerteile
fallen dann unkontrolliert zu Boden und
da kann noch etwas zweites passieren
entweder wird diese Rakete die
feindliche in der Luft sofort zerstört
oder die fliegt ebenfalls noch weiter
hat möglicherweise auch noch Rest
Sprengstoff in sich drin und stürzt dann
ebenfalls unkontrollierter und ich denke
diese Episode die wir jetzt heute
betrachtet haben ist so einen Mischung
aus beiden und ähm wir müssen natürlich
den Ausgang der untersuchen abwarten
aber ich denke das ist ein mögliches
Ergebnis dass wir in den Trümmerteilen
also sowohl Reste der ukrainischen
Flugabwehrrakete finden als auch Reste
der russischen die den eigentlichen
Angriff durchführen sollte
ein Schwerpunkt gerade auf der
Pressekonferenz da wird mich ihre
Einschätzung auch noch interessieren das
ging so ein bisschen in die Richtung
sind denn die Systeme der NATO die auch
im Osten stationiert sind aktiviert
worden da hat Stoltenberg gesagt die
sind rund um die Uhr aktiv das sei auch
in diesem Fall gewesen und er hat gesagt
naja das funktioniert dann so wir
schauen uns das an was kommt da für ein
Objekt und die Einschätzung war eben da
ukrainische Luftabwehrrakete also hätte
man da die die Meinung gehabt dass das
keinen keinen Angriff sozusagen
Voraussagen würde und deswegen das
Ergebnis so sei wie es eben sei die
Frage war aber ob das dann auch ein
Fehler der nato-systeme gewesen ist wie
ist da ihre Einschätzung
nein das würde ich nicht so sehen das
ist einfach die generelle Art wie eine
Luftabwehr funktioniert also sie müssen
trennen zwischen der radareinheit die
den Luftraum passiv überwacht und die
ist tatsächlich 257 die ist ständig
aktiv und schaut einfach welche Objekte
gibt es per jetzt gerade im Luftraum und
welche Flugbahn dann haben die das ist
im Prinzip genauso wie auch bei der
zivilen luftraum-überwachung die schaut
ja auch quasi ständig welche Flugzeuge
sind gerade in meinem Bereich mit
welchen Transponder aber militärisch
stellt sich dann eben die Frage wenn ich
jetzt ein Objekt beobachte das
eigentlich nicht da sein dürfte also
sprich kein ziviles Flugzeug keine
militärischen Körper sondern jetzt kommt
etwas Unbekanntes was mache ich jetzt so
und dann ist die Frage haben sie
Effektoren und was ist die Doktrin für
den Abschuss dieser Effektoren also ist
ihre Doktrin ich schieße sofort auf
alles was kommt oder warten Sie erstmal
ab und machen eine Klassifizierung
es ist gefährlich Luftabwehrsysteme so
zu betreiben sie quasi sagen egal was
herkommt ich schieße sofort drauf weil
es könnte ja auch in ziviles Objekt sein
dass ich z.B verliert hat also nein ich
würde das nicht so sehen aber man muss
auch ganz klar sagen das Radar in Lagune
von dem ich vorhin gesprochen habe ist
eines der stärksten Natur war da habe in
Südost Polen und in der ganzen Ostflanke
der NATO überhaupt also es ist wirklich
so dass die NATO das nicht sehen würde
oder die polnischen Streitkräfte was da
geflogen kommt wichtiger Einordnung
vielen Dank fürs Verständnis und eine
Abschlussfrage noch an sie an Sie Herr
Kolb das sind ihre Informationen
Erkenntnisse auch darüber wie jetzt
sozusagen die weiteren Treffen
Beratungen und Ermittlungen aussehen
also kann man schon sagen wie das jetzt
in der nächsten Zeit weitergehen wird
was wissen Sie über die Prozesse und
auch Informationsflüsse
mehr es gibt ja einen gut eingespielten
Prozess nämlich den randsteinprozess das
heißt dass sie die regelmäßigen Treffen
vor allem der militärischen Vertreter
auf der us-amerikanischen Airways
Rammstein in Deutschland und wenn die
sich das nächste Mal treffen ich denke
da wird ganz klar letztens Land aus
dieser Episode im Vordergrund stehen
davon abgesehen erwarte ich mir aber
auch stärkere Einzelhandlungen einzelner
Staaten sowie Stolberg das heute
angekündigt hat das heißt also es wird
wahrscheinlich eine Mischung geben
sowohl konzentrierte Aktion im Rahmen
der Rammstein Konferenz und da müssen
wir natürlich dann auf die nächste
Sitzung genau hinschauen alles auch
Sofortmaßnahmen
vielen Dank Markus von der
Militärakademie der ETH in Zürich für
diese Einschätzungen und Hintergründe
zum Raketeneinschlag in Polen herzlichen
Dank danke
schönen Tag noch
wir schalten jetzt zu unserem Reporter
daran Hassan Sade er ist in Saray im
Nordwesten der Ukraine 200 Kilometer
entfernt von der polnischen Grenze hallo
erstmal daran grüß Dich
hallo
daran was sind deine aktuellen Eindrücke
und Informationen vor Ort auch ja wie
reagiert die Ukraine und auch Präsident
selenski auf diesen Hinweis dass es sich
eben um eine ukrainische Luft
abwehrrakete gehandelt haben soll
am deutlichsten hat sich am Anfang das
Außenministerium geäußert von der
Ukraine und sehr betont dass man auf
keinen Fall die russische Sichtweise
übernehmen solle nicht auf die
Propaganda eingehen solle und hat
eindringlich daran erinnert wie es
damals bei dem Flug ähm
Absturz der sich als Abschluss entpuppte
im Osten der Ukraine war mittlerweile
hat sich eher die Sicht des haben das
Verteidigungsministeriums durchgesetzt
das ist ein äh das ist sehr große und
intensive Untersuchungen Bedarf und
damit Ermittlung man wissen noch nicht
genau Bescheid um welchen Raketentyp ist
es handele die Flugbahn sei noch nicht
bekannt diese Untersuchungen müssen in
aller Ruhe ganz intensiv durchgeführt
werden erst dann könnte man nach
Abschluss der Ermittlungen sich ein Bild
über die Lage machen das betont das ähm
russische das ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerium der
präsidentenberater Prodigy gerade
wiederum betont dass die
Gesamtverantwortung dafür und da ist er
auch der fast kein Blatt Papier zwischen
die NATO und die und der ukrainischen
Einschätzung dass die Verantwortung
dafür bei Russland liege weil Russland
diesen Krieg begonnen hat und natürlich
die Ukraine dazu zwingt
Luftabwehrraketen einzusetzen um seine
eigene Bevölkerung zu schützen und
daraus folgt natürlich für die Ukraine
der Wunsch der von der Bevölkerung schon
in märz in den Himmel gerufen wurde eine
Flugverbotszone und natürlich ist das
auch ein sage ich fast Traum der
ukrainischen Regierung was allerdings
natürlich eine ganz andere
Einmischung der NATO in diesen Krieg
bedeuten würde das sogar die ersten
Reaktionen daran lass uns noch mal auf
die gesamtgemängelage aber von gestern
blicken in der Ukraine Kiew hat ja
gesagt dass es 90 Raketenangriffe
gestern gegeben haben soll
also was genau ist da gestern in der
Ukraine passiert von Seiten russische
Raketenangriffe vielleicht beschreibst
du uns die Situation in die auch dieser
Raketeneinschlag dann in Polen passiert
ist
nach unseren Erkenntnissen nach unserem
Kenntnissen ist ein
Bomber der russischen Armee aufgestiegen
und hat seine gesamte Ladung mit
lang mit Mittelstreckenraketen auf die
Ukraine abgefeuert es wurden über das
ganze Land Ziele der Infrastruktur
versucht zu treffen in Kiew ist schon
bekannt geworden dass das nicht gelungen
ist sondern dass vor allem Wohnhäuser
getroffen wurden es sind Menschen
gestorben und die Ukraine ist natürlich
was die Infrastruktur angeht enorm unter
Druck man sprach die offizielle Stellen
gaben an dass 7 Millionen Menschen in
der Ukraine im Moment ohne
Stromversorgung sein
das wäre noch eine Abschlussfrage auch
an Dich wie ist denn da der aktuelle
Stand die Meldungen hat sich das wieder
etwas beruhigt sind die Menschen wieder
mit Strom versorgt wie ist da der
aktuelle Stand
der aktuelle Stand ist dass die
gezielten und geplanten Stromabschaltung
im ganzen Land stattfinden und das
bedeutet im Alltag der Ukraine dass man
wirklich aufpassen muss wann man
Dinge benutzt wie zum Beispiel Aufzüge
die von Strom von der Stromversorgung
abhängen es bleiben Leute die das
einfach vergessen haben oder in der Eile
denken ist gelingt noch in auf einen
Aufzügen hängen ähm ihr normales Leben
muss danach organisiert werden
hinzukommt das nach solchen Luft
Angriffen auch Infrastruktur getroffen
wird sei es umschaltleitung sei es
Kraftwerke und dann kommt es zu
plötzlichen Ausfällen in Gebieten also
die der Winter man sieht ja selber wo
ich gerade stehe im Regen es wird immer
kälter und die Lage wird für die
Menschen immer prekäre
Dankeschön daran Hassan Sade für diese
Eindrücke aus Sani in der Ukraine 200 km
ungefähr entfernt von der polnischen
Grenze herzlichen dank dir
und wir schauen jetzt noch mal gemeinsam
auch auf Reaktionen aus Deutschland zu
diesem Raketeneinschlag in Polen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat sich dazu
geäußert und da hören wir in einer
Aussage von ihm rein
zunächst mal bin ich traurig über die
Opfer dieser Raketen
Anschläge die in Polen stattgefunden
haben auch über die Zerstörung ich habe
auch nicht sofort in Verbindung gesetzt
mit dem polnischen Präsidenten und eben
das Mitgefühl der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Deutschlands und mein persönliches
Mitgefühl übermittelt klar ist dass wir
jetzt sehr vorsichtig sein müssen es
dürfen keine Gerichte über die Frage
entstehen besten Rakete das nun war die
da eingeschlagen ist das muss sorgfältig
untersucht werden und das haben wir
veranlasst auch der amerikanische
Präsident hat der polnischen Regierung
angeboten bei der Untersuchung zu helfen
und wir wissen natürlich gleichzeitig
dass das alles egal von wem die Rakete
abgeschossen wurde und welches Ziel sie
eigentlich hatte nicht stattfinden würde
wenn es nicht den Krieg Russland gegen
die Ukraine gäbe und auch die fruchtbare
Kriegsführung
soweit also eine erste Reaktion von
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz zum
Raketeneinschlag in Polen das ganze
Interview findet ihr auch noch mal auf
ZDF heute wir sind am Ende unseres
Streams wir haben zusammengefasst was
wir aktuell Wissen über den
Raketeneinschlag in Polen bei dem
mindestens zwei Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sind und was wir eben noch
nicht wissen weitere Erkenntnisse laufen
das hat Nato-Generalsekretär Jens
doltenberg auch auf der Pressekonferenz
bestätigt ist soll heute noch ein
Treffen mit der NATO Kontaktgruppe geben
um auch da noch mal zu schauen wie die
Luftabwehrsysteme im Osten verstärkt
werden können wie man auch der Ukraine
weiterhelfen kann vielen Dank an Euch
fürs mit diskutieren fürs kommentieren
und auch fürs Fragen stellen und unsere
Gesprächspartner und dann werden wir
auch euch weiter informieren natürlich
über die Hintergründe rund um die
Situation auf ZDF heute in der App oder
auch im TV bleibt also dran und macht's
gut bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss